foreign
[Music]
there's a lot of blood and gore in games
but only the goriest most brutal deaths
will do for this video and I mean deaths
not just torture or pain they have to
die also keep in mind because I'm going
with the most gruesome deaths in games
there's going to be spoilers with that
being said here are top 12 goriest video
game deaths
we're gonna start with Manhunt 2. you
get three levels of execution in this
game level one being quick and dirty
level two being a bit more bloody and
level three where you saw a guy's head
open
[Music]
You Gotta Give a nod to Sniper Elite
three when you shoot someone in the
testicles and you see the inside of
their body and all those parts explode
and you hear every horrible noise as if
the testicle itself is screaming for
help
[Music]
all right
God of War is notorious for blood and
gore and everything you love about
gruesome boss battles God of War
ascension really showcases some of these
moments that the series was known for
and honestly we could pick any one of
these and it would be a good fit but the
spot goes to the curb stomp and Spike
gut scene
[Applause]
foreign
Bioshock will upset you there's no
shortage of Gore in the series in the
original Jack slowly kills Ryan with a
golf club after repeated hits to the
skull but you don't get very far in
infinite before you're ripping people's
faces off with your sky hook
stop man stop him
come on
the Resident Evil series doesn't shy
away from trying to make you squirm
Resident Evil 6 wasn't known for the
best reasons but we all remember the fan
scene
[Music]
Call of Duty Black Ops 2 starts out
letting you know that people are gonna
die horribly it all begins with the
scene of a dude burning to death in a
car but I gotta say having your kneecaps
blown off and then your throat slit with
a wire really takes the cake
wow
torture is typically where you put
someone through so much pain they
confess information but in Wolfenstein
the New Order they just straight up kill
the dude
[Music]
foreign
The Evil Within puts you through some
[__] you're always being hunted falling
into some weird meat grinder machine
fighting off Barbed wires zombies
There's that dude with a pointy Hammer
that wants you dead but there's this
really upsetting skinny lady with long
nails that doesn't like your face and
she gets the number five spot
all right
Tomb Raider reboot shocked players with
how gruesome some of Lara's deaths were
they showed her getting smashed cut and
impaled in dozens of scenarios but the
one that made the list a pull through
Lara's head
every Dead Space game isn't just violent
it's gross you're getting vomit in your
face there's a monster with a claw that
rips you open but eye stuff that's
something special
really
[Music]
good
until dawn shocked everyone when it
revealed it wasn't just your everyday
teen slasher not only were there
surprise crazy monsters hunting the
teens but they were brutally killing
them these teens die horribly in all
sorts of ways but the most upsetting one
is probably the jaw death
laughs
[Music]
Mortal Kombat has most every fatality
you can think of and they are all
gruesome they're honestly all winners
here I could probably pick the entire
list from this game and it would be 100
accurate they're that gross
difficult to pick a winner here
overall though there's just something
about Molina punching through the
opponent's torso with such force that as
they scream and try to escape they cut
themselves in half and then she eats
them
[Music]
winner winner chicken dinner well those
are our top picks for the most gruesome
gory and brutal decks in games which one
seems the Glorious to you are you
permanently scarred and you just want us
to know fantastic throw it in the
comments below and stay tuned for more
lists by game spots
foreign